le festival de cannes c'est le rendez
vous des hautes sphères du cinéma c'est
aussi pour un jeune réalisateur un lieu
idéal pour se développer
originaire de plaisir quentin dupieux en
est à son cinquième festival à la tête
d'une société de production in
multiplient à cannes les rendez vous
d'affaires
objectif financer ses projets
audiovisuels qui se chiffrent pour
certains à plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'euros
[Musique]
quentin depuis la dernière fois qu'on
vous avez suivi à cannes c'était il ya
deux ans vous présentiez ici un court
métrage au chante film corner qu'est ce
qui s'est passé pour vous depuis ses
deux ans et bat depuis ses deux ans j'ai
monté ma société de production
velvet cette production on s'occupe
principalement à deux axes principaux de
travailler une partie publicité à la
fois sur la france et l'international
notamment avec la chine et une partie
production de longs métrages
là aussi avec une portée internationale
et multiculturelle
quand on gère une société de production
forcément au début d'un projet
audiovisuel ya une question qui revient
c'est le financement comment ça se passe
quand on veut monter un projet et bien
quand on veut monter un projet de
production de longs métrages en fut
classé déjà beaucoup de poids beaucoup
de patience et beaucoup de rencontres de
réseaux nous nous on amène des projets
donc c'est toujours le jeu c'est de
convaincre des investisseurs de venir
investir dans ce conte dans l'est dans
les films qu'on a envie de développer de
produire donc tout le tout le jeu de la
production et là c'est à dire d'aller
voir le maximum de gens de trouver des
financements dans le plus de pays
possible suivant les productions qu'on
veut faire sur les pays qu'on veut
toucher les marchés qu'on veut toucher
et d'aller chercher des investisseurs
des financiers des gens qui croient dans
le projet pour les emmener avec nous
dans cette aventure pour pour créer tout
ça quand vous serez à cannes jusqu'à la
quasi fin du festival jusqu'au 18 mai à
quoi ressemblent vos journées
concrètement depuis le début de ce
festival bien concrètement c'est
beaucoup de rendez-vous a principalement
c'est beaucoup beaucoup de rendez vous
avec voilà qu'on a préparé en amont des
gens qu'on rencontre aussi des soirées
et fameuse soirée cannoise où il ya
beaucoup de travail de networking et de
rencontres aussi et qui nous permet
voilà chaque jour d'avoir platini s'est
établie entre les rendez-vous les
déjeuners et les dîners
et d'enchaîner tout ça vous n'allez pas
nous dire qu'ils allaient rencontrer
mais ce que des personnes sont
intéressées par les projets que vous
présentez on a beaucoup de chance cette
année c'est un fait celle qui se passe
très bien pour nous on a de l'intérêt
notamment du côté de la chine on a de
l'intérêt aussi du côté de l'angleterre
et des états unis avec des projets qu'on
a notamment un projet entre l'angleterre
et la france donc ça se passe plutôt
très bien on est très content avec mon
associé le festival ces rendez vous avec
les potentiels financiers se déroule ici
au sein du palais du festival n'ont
finalement très très peu c'est plutôt
dans les restaurants dans les hôtels
dans les bars finalement le palais sert
beaucoup pour la vente des films souvent
des jeunes qui sont déjà faits on est
quand même à une étape de financement on
est moins formel jamais dans les
rendez-vous les lieux dans lesquels on
se rend compte avec avec les
investisseurs et les autres les
coproducteurs une dernière chose c'est
votre cinquième festival
il faut être ici à cannes surtout quand
on est à la tête d'une société de
production il faut il faut être présent
ici et tiennent effectivement en tant
que c'était de production c'est vraiment
important pour nous d'être présents à
cannes c'est le seul moment de l'année
des représentants dans tous les pays du
monde sont présents même lieu au même
endroit avec la même passion du cinéma
et pour développer des projets justement
là-dessus donc c'est très important pour
nous et c'est une plate forme incroyable
chaque année merci content du puits
merci beaucoup merci aux catégories
[Musique]
focus à présent sur un film
subventionnées par la région ile de
france celui ci fait partie de la
sélection de la quinzaine des
réalisateurs festival parallèle
amine de philippe faucon c'est
l'histoire d'un sénégalais venus
travailler en france il a laissé
derrière lui son épouse et ses enfants
sa vie solitaire va basculer le jour où
il rencontre et gabriel avec qui une
relation se noue amine vous faites une
pause
alors ça y est vous allez terminer ce
soir
khan 60 18 touche à sa fin demain la
suite de nos rencontres avec les
yvelinois de la croisette
[Musique]